all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito ibantis and very
very happy to see thai guy travis today
how are we doing sirs first to start
with let's start with travis man travis
how are you how you doing brother how
you doing i'm doing good man i've you
know finished my my uh one of my reviews
went live uh today for windjammers2 and
now i'm playing dying light too so
um
yeah i'm gonna be busy man i gotta i
gotta play 500 hours before uh the
embargo lifts on february 2nd so just a
little just a little bit of time to put
in right
yeah you know what's funny is every time
i think this game has enough in it they
post something
i like bragging about how long it is
this week they bragged that i had like
350 000 like uh voice acted lines or
something like that i definitely dm
like i want the transcripts i want uh i
want travis to transcribe the entire
script before review is out
yeah i just love how
how much the games industry has evolved
on this issue used to be that we loved
hearing that games were like oh this is
like the biggest game we've ever made
it's hundreds of hours and now somebody
tells us the game is like 700 hours and
we're like no like i don't want to play
that that's way too long so
anyway i'm busy with that uh but it's uh
it's been good man no doubt no doubt
good busy man sure good to see you
brother i know you know you had some
stuff going on and like i said it's
always good to see you man i'll be
feeling better and of course we have
before we get to our special guests we
have a famous cheetah who is uh
in the realm of it advanced i believe
he's gonna be dancing
if you've followed me you've probably
seen my
lots of shameless plugging of my new
merch we've got the ibanta shaker so the
eye shakers you guys have seen us use
the stainless steel 26 ounce blender
attachment but it's got the abantas logo
but it's got like the aggressive cheetah
so it's actually a different look than
pretty much any logo that i've actually
got on the internet so kind of a unique
variant you have two more days from when
we're recording this podcast if you want
to go get one the link will be in chat
if you guys just literally go to
advanced gg but um
big one is right there in chat yeah if
you guys are curious about that one
that's the big one um i jumped into
horizon zero dawn yesterday i knocked
out about seven and a half hours
it's a pretty good long stream i think i
did most of the
eastern starting continent because
that's what i did actually when i played
before because i played on ps4 when it
came out for about that long and then
breath of the wild knocked me off in
destiny and then i never got back to it
and then finally now i've got it on pc
so i figured i'd jump in so i'm pretty
much back to where i was
uh because there's the dlc up north
which is above my level that's like in
game but it's the entire rest of the
continent i've never seen
i'm actually right there so nice just
running around and playing that just
seeing how much fun that thing is
being as it's an old game even though
it's just been ported and looks prettier
and that's 60 frames
oh yeah it's gotta be hidden it's
gorgeous the combat's still fun the
dinosaurs i just like enjoy the combat
in that game between the bow the traps
and everything and i'm like if they take
what's here and i know people like the
story too it's like you know a lot of
people close friend of mine it's like
really high on his list if they take
what's already there and they just like
expand and i've heard the melee combats
better like i
playstation's about to have like a
banger in just the start of the year so
i'm looking forward to that but
yeah what about you sir cog yeah not
just been all busy man you know keeping
up the podcast in six zillion podcasts
and
put down content or shout out to mr
maddie please put out a good one with uh
the dev from nobody saves the world
that's the uh the makers of guacamelee
nice and they just launched this weekend
in game pass very fun cutesy art style
absolutely hilarious game we learned a
lot of stuff about that clearly there's
been a huge amount of news in the
industry right now between microsoft
microsoft and activision and
acquisitions and everybody's a legal
expert and you know liability and
anti-trust i heard everything
season gaming brother i got what i have
one what is it one fourth or one third
we got one third here and then two
thirds of season games two thirds two
thirds now complete but um yeah it's
really good check that out we just have
to get the homeless uh wizard in here as
well or whatever whatever you call
whatever you call it you gotta get there
you get
aids you gotta get your man trapped and
the slander is legendary for that you
gotta you don't know what he'd be
putting at work on last word with who he
podcasts with but anyway enough of that
but yeah it's been busy man fun week and
another fun weekend plan but we got a
special guest that's been very patient
while we've been blow v8 yes so let's
start this thing officially now since
you know the rest of it's just like
pre-show
welcome to the last word number 181
this week started off with one of the
biggest mic drop moments in the history
of video games and boy has it made waves
many of which we won't know the full
implications of for quite some time we
are less than five weeks away from the
launch of the destiny 2 expansion many
of us hope it really is a game changer
but before we get there we we get to
discuss the breadcrumbs that we are fed
each week until it goes live
and once again we are joined by a very
well-timed guest to discuss these bit of
to discuss this bit of info bungie has
dropped this guest started her gaming
journey with her brother on that good
old genesis platform
enjoyed some grand theft auto on ps2 but
xbox is where she spent a lot of time in
modern gaming while the adventures of
batman and far cry have been fun we
actually have orca whales yes i said
whales to thank for our guest getting
into this franchise we all adore in her
effort to advocate for freeing of orcas
from captivity a noble cause she's still
fighting for by the way a fellow whale
lover nudged her to check out this
multiplayer game called destiny and
while she tended to stay in her single
player lane she gave this world of
guardians a chance it's been a bit of an
up and down journey but because her road
was rough she has taken her love of
trying to make the world a better place
and tries to help ensure guardians have
a positive rate experience and even
teach them to pay it forward as well so
let's welcome a guardian with over 300
clears on the new vault of glass
founding member of the v4 vengeance clan
enjoys both true crime podcasts and some
slayer rock supporter of the southern
resident action center helping the
salish i'm probably gonna butcher that
sea orcas and mom who balances saving
the world and galaxy each and every day
the one the only the vertigo vixen how
are you doing this evening sarah
oh my gosh
that
that
was
amazing
introduction i'm
i'm doing really good i'm so happy to be
here
pleasure to have you pleasure to have
you i hope you're doing well
i see what you did there yeah
and it begins early and it begins
i love it
so you want to set it off we got
questions we got things to talk about
yes
um
i can't steal the gaming history i got
to give you that one because there's a
reason
yeah yeah it's
it's really impressive you know as far
as like what kind of drew you're in the
games and stuff like that i think it's
very very so i wanted to talk about the
playstation aspect the vice city aspect
and then i want to talk about the xbox
uh aspect as well you know i mean so
kind of like your early gaming history
like what what were those influences for
those who don't know
um so the playstation i just really kind
of came by the playstation the guy i was
dating
like um
i
had my daughter very young i was 15
whenever i had her so of course there's
a big chunk there that i did not you
know i just cut out gaming altogether
because
i was very busy so
once you know once i got to just like
have more chill time it was like okay i
can kind of get back into this so
my i was we were just dating at the time
but he had brought home a playstation 2
and it was like oh that's cool
let me see you know so
we started playing vice city and i just
kind of pushed him out of there and was
like mine
this is mine now you
you go do your thing
i might let you
show me like the cheat codes or hold the
cheat code sheet for me while i do this
but
yeah so i really just really loved that
game it was so much fun just like i had
never played anything like that before
because i was coming from
you know
when i was younger just playing like
sega genesis and like sonic and tekken
you know stuff like that wait hold on
hold on i got to stop you you just named
some classic friend i just cannot let
you breathe through some of my favorite
games
are you a tekken mistress are you a
tekken vixen talk to me about this
so
i think like
i was always like very competitive
loved it i loved it so me and my me and
my ex-husband i think that's really why
we fell in love is because we played we
played tekken and we played
um
oh we got what was it galaga they had
galaga they used it
in the arcades they had that on a disc
and so we just like sat there and just
took it all the way to 99999 you know so
wow i mean him and i really did like
share that love of gaming and and it was
competitive and but fun you know like i
loved that i loved that so it went from
that playstation and then
um a few years later like
um me and my daughter
we me my ex-husband got divorced or
whatever so me and my daughter when we
were going to do our own thing it was
like okay well
should we
i mean this xbox was looking really cool
because it had the whole connects thing
and that was that was wild because that
was really new too you know that whole
oh yeah just like moving and yeah being
able to like be a part of the game like
that there was so much fun you're not
watching the video by the way you just
missed a lot of fun so yeah
we were totally ridiculous while you're
talking continue we're doing our
connection
so we went with xbox because the connect
was so cool and we it was just it was
just too neat so that's actually how we
got into xbox was just like
it was too cool we had to go with it and
then
the batman's and
i mean i
was so neat
so neat it had really come a long way
from vice city a little bit to jumping
into like xbox and playing yeah the
arkham city it was just like oh wow
that's awesome
i got tons of stuff but i'm going to let
you guys open it up because i don't want
to hoard the questions
he's just
like it's it's it's hilarious when
anybody puts genesis on here because
that's what cognito's like that was his
bag when he grew up it was like me i'm
going like
yeah i was like so for me i missed
genesis i was all stepping i don't do
sega until my buddy got dreamcast
because i never everything i was around
was like nes snes 64 but my buddy got
dreamcast and i remember crazy taxi is
what we went probably spent the most
time on on dreamcast that and soul
calibur
both of those but yes i was like i
played tekken tekken tag a little bit
when i was younger
tekken's always a fun one
i can't remember which year it was but
it was that
mario lemieux hockey i can't remember
what year it was like 93 maybe
that
that was really really good i really
enjoyed that on sega genesis one person
knows what game you're talking about
right now
it's a deep cut
one of my clan mates he's he's a
pittsburgh guy he wouldn't know about he
should know about that one now yeah that
was a classic one before the um the nhl
pa kind of games kind of took off that
was during the age of the the superstar
licensing where you'd get the one
superstar wayne gretzky hockey here
you know pat riley tommy
you know that kind of thing so yeah it's
funny you said that because yeah that's
definitely a deep cut for sure for sure
yeah
nice
so before to take a step i was just
gonna say to take a step off of the uh
video game path um
i gotta ask on
orca whales i was trying not to call
them killer whales by the way because i
wasn't sure if that's like something you
don't want to hear i honestly don't know
okay cause like you know by both i'm
like free willy that's the whale
everybody's thinking of you're good
there yes um so what like
did you like them as a child like where
did all this start and then kind of what
got you into the advocation that you
have been trying and i loved free willy
i loved that and i think like even when
when i was young and a lot of people
were going to sea world it wasn't
something that i really like had the
desire to do which i'll throw a desire
in there for you
i think i missed something i missed
girls
oh he was he was in the other room we
were talking about that
but um
so yeah it never really felt right it
wasn't like i admired them but it wasn't
something where i wanted to go it seemed
not right that they were
supposed to live in the ocean and they
had them
i don't know
so
it just didn't like sit right with me
even as a child to just have such a big
creature just in captivity like that
and then
i mean you know whenever i was little we
didn't have
as much like resources the resources and
stuff like that like the internet to
really like look in to dig into things
and
find people that think the same way that
you do
but there's some downs to that but we'll
get to that in another day
yes it's a good and bad thing well my
daughter there was a film called
blackfish yes and
she was like you need to watch this and
i watched it
and you know it made me kind of sick
feeling and then i watched it again and
i was like well what can we do
and because i was it just affected me
just seeing just everything about it and
learning like so much about them and
their family ties and how smart they are
and just their languages just everything
about them i was like what can we do
and you can't really just like take
these
these whales and put them back in the
ocean you know after they were born in
captivity that's not fair to them either
so i think the best solution would be to
just not breed them anymore so that's
really what we became
what we were really advocating for which
we were kind of like
in a different little kind of niche in
the whole thing because a lot of people
were like you have to free them and
you know or they were pro-captivity but
we were just like well just don't breed
anymore you know just let the ones live
out their lives in captivity but stop
creating the problem and
and we went down to we had never my
daughter me and my daughter we had never
like flown or anything but i was like
we're doing it we went down to florida
we went down there and protested at sea
world and wow they ended up yeah
eventually they ended up they stopped
breeding the stuff the breeding program
so we got we got our way
it worked powerful story powerful story
for sure
yeah i mean i could really do a deep
dive but
we don't want to go that we don't want
to go that crazy into the whales but
i mean and it was really neat like it
was something that her and i like we
shared that passion together and it was
really cool and it was cool being part
of like a really big protest down there
but
the the best protest i'd really only
gone to two but her and i we had gone to
las vegas one time and we went out to
the mirage and just protested out there
because they had dolphins out there and
they're you know they're very smart it's
the desert and it's just kind of like
weird but
so we went out there and we just made
some signs and
that was so
so cool we just connected with people
and they would come up and talk to us
and that was just like the connections
that we made and had like real
conversations with people about it
instead of
going down to like sea world where it
was huge and everybody's just kind of
screaming and you can't really hear
anybody when they're yelling you know so
it was much it was much cooler when it
was just like really low-key and so
you got in before it was cool you got
the low-key
it's always been cool i think yeah
no respect for you for uh defending you
what you're passionate about and a lot
of people don't back action into it so
salute to you yeah that is very very
important to at least continue the
discussion right constructively as well
as act on it
yeah i have a hard time like if i do
feel passionate about something i do
have a hard time not being active
like on twitter and stuff people would
be like that's you're an activist and i
was like well i'd rather be an activist
than an inactivist
because you're not getting anything done
if i'm going to talk about it i want to
be about it you know
talk this i'll fix it
respect respect yeah thank you
i mean i had to ask definitely seemed
like something you were passionate about
for sure but another thing you were
passionate about see now you gotta tell
and i was gonna say like at least tell
the story of how that got you into
obviously what we're gonna talk about
tonight like is it just somebody you met
in a connection and like yes like i had
heard destiny had heard the word before
but you know i was coming from
xbox and playing by myself and like one
of my buddies was like you should play
destiny and i was like online gaming
like i don't want to play with a bunch
of
strangers and then
yes
so i had kind of dismissed it
and then i
you know i was like doing my whale thing
and had met some really cool people and
one of those guys with stew and he was
like really into destiny and i was like
okay okay so
i i bought it and just like ran around
the moon for like a month i
yes i thought that those would make me
jump higher i was like how are you have
you had he had a double jump i was like
how did you get that he's like well you
have to upgrade
upgrade jump yep
so
yeah that is true i actually forget the
days the old skill trees like you didn't
have the nodes unlocked and you played
enough to level up your character as
well so now it's like pick them
yeah
absolutely uh travelity thoughts on the
destiny early d1 days does she take the
thing
yeah so you said you were jumping around
the moon so that's obviously destiny one
right yes what uh
around what time did you start playing
like what uh what was the expansion were
you taken king it was um
the taking king the whole collection was
out by the time i started
so there was so much to do and it was so
much just like
awesome stuff you know it was
so much content so many different things
going on because it was just all there
so
i got busy i ended
i ended d1 with
max grimoire i had wow the only exotic i
didn't have was that emblem
from trials
from like really the early days and
trials because
then is that the one uh-huh
yeah there was like an exotic emblem i
guess like really really early so i
didn't get that but every other exotic
all the stuff i had to have it i was
like i'm 100 in this game and
i mean
ended up pretty much doing that it was
it was just it had me you know it was so
much fun
yes
teddy would be proud if you hate this
is that your first shooter because it
based on your um on your history doesn't
sound like you played a lot of shooters
before destiny is destiny the first
first person shooter you've really
attached to yeah yes i didn't play like
halo or anything like that i missed all
of that so it was basically
like just
you know
single
games like batman but
um i mean i did play far cry that's not
really a shooter but i mean i was
playing games like that third person i
mean
yes it's like third person shooter it's
kind of like
a bridge from your action to your
shooters it was your in between right
destiny was definitely
different
just different than anything that i had
ever really played before
cool cool also um what i thought is
really cool is you know one thing i'm
very passionate about is what kind of
made me stick with destiny was raiding
right and and
you know for me obviously he knows the
story of a million times you know i'm
saying but
vaulted glass was kind of that made me
say okay there's more to this game i i
was planning like a traditional game you
know you get to your for what forever 29
mode you beat your campaign or whatever
and i'm like okay that's it and to be
honest wasn't super impressed i was like
okay it's good this bucket's good but i
remember you know
getting into a raid now you started
taking king era so i want to know like
first raid and then how did the hooks
get in
to then what to end up evolving to what
you end up becoming right yeah so the
first read i didn't even know what we
were doing i was probably it was like
four of us
and it was some guys
it was actually the original guy that
was like you should play destiny and i
was like
you know it was that guy him and a
couple of his friends i ended up like
messaging him like hey i'm playing that
game you know so
he i played with him and his friends a
little bit here and there and they took
me into the vault of glass and it was
just like
i remember we were doing templar and now
i know you know that we were doing
templar but we were like standing behind
the relic and
i he was like protecting us with it i
was just like i don't know what to do
yeah and my light level was so low it
was just miserable i was just death over
and over but
i don't think i remember whenever we had
we were in atheon and we were
teleporting like randomly and i was just
like i don't know why you know i didn't
know understand why i kept teleporting i
was like i don't know
they're like where are you
i used to mess that up
there was only four of us
so of course the raid just to have fun
like what's happening right i don't know
they were torturing me they were like oh
let's do this and then like it just was
it was all over the place and i didn't
even understand that it was a raider or
anything
so later
much later i
i met some people through the 100 it was
well one guy in particular that kind of
introduced me into some other people and
i was i had signed up on there because i
you know
you could only go higher
and
get your light higher you know certain
ways it was like reading or you were
gonna have to do like challenge of
the elders or do trials
so
um i was like well i really what you
know i really want to reign he was like
well let's raid and i said okay so we
were doing king's fall and stuff and it
was just brutal it was absolutely brutal
those guys wanted to do hard mode and
i mean i really just didn't even
fight it to the fire
oh yeah they just threw me in there and
it was just horrible i remember just
being in tears sometimes that like
totems just like oh my god
i don't know if i'm i'm cut out for this
you know
this may not be for me this may have
been a bad decision
like we would be in oryx and it's like i
don't even know which way is clockwise
you know which way is clockwise because
they're like you know
talking about the the running and stuff
and i'm like
here's the question is oryx in the front
of the back of the room oh he's in the
front for sure
yeah he's definitely in the front
yes
so is tanex and deep stone
phase one
how'd you get from like crying in oryx
to now
and basically being one of the ultimate
sherpas out there like where did because
did it just like
nobody should cry in a raid
so
eventually we just i just started like
meeting cool people along the way and
collecting them and we would be as
helpful as we could be in d1 you know we
would it was a lot of fun just like we
knew a guy that
i mean the first guy that we were really
like helping a lot he he was a he had
some developmental
issues and challenges and stuff so we
were we went all in and just like really
tried to lift him up and it was
so amazing to like
do that for somebody
who just
who didn't think that they could do that
you know what i mean to like be there
helping somebody like to accomplish
things they
just never thought that they would be
able to do so
that kind of like that chirping and
helping i mean it was just like it's
addicting
it's just like i don't want anybody to
struggle
the way that i had felt sometimes i
would not want anybody to have to feel
like that like everybody should
be able to get in there and experience
that and see how much fun it can be
because there's so much like lfgs just a
wasteland sometimes it's real rough you
know so
i definitely want us to be some kind of
a light
in the middle of all that like just you
know oh you have to have all this i love
being able to lfg and just say
you know just be chill
i don't care what you bring
just beat you have you ever made
somebody cry during a raid
maybe aggressive during like a three-man
one of my buddies
only people who deserve this sounds like
yeah it's pretty stressful though yeah
you're like uh we're low manning now
time to buck up
you can't you can't go back on your
decision once you make a call out you
have to stick with it
in the three man i can only imagine yeah
oh my god stress i mean but i have to
ask you really quick um just in general
obviously this is your thing
raining sharpering
so let's do some hierarchy okay let's do
some radioactive real quick
you know where where where do you rank
you know
top top three three raids top three at
least
yeah but
god i love the leviathan okay so we
would have to like
separate d1 from d2 okay okay so let's
do that
yeah my top raid in d1
i mean i love king's fault right
but i really love wrath of the machine
because
it was
it was sweet right it wasn't too long
king's fall is so dark and heavy and i
went through some [ __ ] in kingsville so
whenever like
wrath of the machine came out it was
just like and that was the one we got to
get in there whenever it was i mean we
were ready we prepped we went in there
and we did that omnigul cheese you know
and
and got up to 365 or whatever it was and
i can't even remember what it was but
we just uh
we were you know in there when that raid
actually came out so we got to go in
there and just like figure it all out so
like on all my
all my raids on on d1 i think i'm like
78 79 it's real even until you get to
wrath of the machine and then it's like
almost 200 because i loved that one that
was the one that i was just like oh yeah
yes oh yeah i loved it it's very fun
rate very fun race yes a lot of fun yeah
i i felt they really mastered
rewarding i think that was the the debut
of like deceiva keys yeah
and stuff yeah yes
it really
yeah it rewarded
you even if you did it for the week
there was incentive to keep going you
know the the um what's my man's name
what was it what's his name what was
with the egg what was the boss straight
now oh
no no no no access
one of the coolest things obviously
siege machine i thought that was yeah
the big example i always thought
yeah it is
like but the the aesthetic i always felt
going down
seeing you know what i'm saying the war
mind and then like kind of getting into
yes it was just a very cool tech the
reds the dark colors and
a lot of coordination so so you know
what rat doesn't get a lot of love
graphics around that that's pretty cool
because you're right
i also noticed that people tend to like
the the raid that they did blind first
yeah sounds like that was your first
blind yes absolutely that's like a
pretty common threat i think the first
time yeah you kind of make it your own
yeah you're getting in there and
nobody's just like explaining it to you
you're figuring it out and so it kind of
just makes it yours you know like you
really understand what's happening in
there so
so definitely wrath and then if we come
over to
d2 i mean i
loved leviathan
wow break this down i gotta hear this
one
well i love the fact that you
were running a different raid
every week
basically the same encounters
but it i mean yes you had to know the
different paths and how to get around in
there i mean there were skips and stuff
like that but it kind of changed it up a
little bit i really enjoyed that i
enjoyed
um
when prestige came out oh my god i was
like one of the few that
i wanted to do the whole thing everybody
was really like farming checkpoints and
stuff at that time and i was like no
we're it's the whole thing and i
remember people just giving me so much
hell
on lfg because they were like
no cheese because we wouldn't cheese
gauntlets or anything like that and they
were like that's stupid and just giving
me or no what they were doing they were
cheese in like the boss room remember
they would like send somebody the cheese
was they would kick somebody to orbit
yeah
and then it would just like no ads would
spawn and it took i remember somebody
doing it and i was like this is
ridiculous
just do the encounter
i remember just get good that was like
stupid especially since the hardest part
of that encounter isn't even the ads
it's like
the whole you know the darkness world
yes yeah just missing the holes and not
getting pooped over basically like that
like nine times out of ten that's what
ruins the encounter like why do we care
about ads that much does it really
yeah i don't know i was always in the
darkness world so i was had like that
smug superiority
you guys stay in the throat
i'm gonna be in the shadow realm in here
thanks
shadow realm
doing all the hard work here
that dude that encounter sucks
oh my gosh
it was more than like when it was
sucking you in and like if you hit a
pebble you'd fly off and like there was
just a lot of inconsistencies sometimes
some
sometimes you would go over the wind
wall you would just you just slide right
over it even when you were like crouched
and all that stuff and people always had
like these homegrown rules like oh if
you crouch you're less likely to fall
over which i don't know if it was true
oh my god such an ugh
if you crouch and pull back on your
stick it was supposed to like keep you
from going
i think that's probably
i think that's probably one of my
proudest things is whenever because we
did two man the the boss
so i was in the i was in the uh void
room by myself with
a
midnight crew
and
a uh whisper of the worm
and it was it was hairy but i felt
yeah
it felt pretty good
i mean later on you could go in there
and do it with swords but you know when
we first did it
with at least whisper yeah taking us
back with whispers that comes up again
but that is the unique thing about
leviathan though is like most raids are
relatively linear like you do a boss you
may have in between but there's this
progression forward leviathan is the
only thing that like you have the
underbelly of the inner workings you'd
go different orders it is massive and i
know not everybody loved the castellam i
think that's the opening section because
you had to go back through it each time
if you did it right and then once you
found the shortcuts it was a little more
path but it was just it was a unique
design and it was
it was massive like i mean you they
built two other raids off of that thing
it was so damn big so
oh yeah
i want it really quick before you move
on i just want to give leviathan its
flowers in aesthetic like for the cabal
the royal themes you know you know cup
dawg
the whole you know the whole thing
and like the babies
yeah the veil all the fans i forgot
about yeah
you know it was just it was a thing and
and i will say me personally one of my i
did like the idea of callus i had like
the arrogance and the the thing and you
know what i'm saying
i love the opulence i go from what he
said get fat for i'm sorry what did you
say
i was gonna say it's also the first time
that a raid has like a story like he's
talking to you throughout it and stuff
which is yeah
i guess my review of leviathan is
basically that i think it's the most
ambitious raid they've ever done in
terms of mechanics it had like stuff
they'd never tried before it had the you
know kind of open world nature of it it
had a stealth boss encounter where
you're fighting the dogs you know which
they've never had never did it had the
callous uh you know darkness world thing
the problem is it tries so many new
things half of the encounters don't work
as encounters like the the stealth
encounter dog thing like it's such a
good idea but stealth and dodgy yeah
and then sometimes they don't see you
i'm like dude i walked right in front of
the guy oh my god yes
prestige i think the dogs were the worst
i think though if you did it in prestige
they were all right it was just like
good luck to you
yes so annoying dumb spores oh you're
taking me back you take it back but
continue
because i can go i mean
it worked though i think that raid would
be really like loved it's just that half
the encounters like
don't work if they did like i feel like
it would have been really great so
yeah i mean that's it's hard to go wrong
with you know wrath of the machine and
leviathan i like the unique answers
because everybody's like yeah multiple
classes are king's fall almost always
and then you got your last wishes and
you hit neither of them which i love we
got some unique answers
nice to see because
i like all the raids for sure but i do
have my favorites absolutely my favorite
things i like the unique nature
well
um before we actually get to the twab i
did want to kind of get everybody's
thoughts because there's no way we can't
talk about this it's a video game
microsoft bought activision and blizzard
and there's no way we can't talk about
it it's literally the biggest video
gaming news that i've ever heard of ever
it'd be like nintendo buying sony like
it's almost it's almost that big if not
bigger by like market cap so
um
sarah if you want to go first if you've
had any thoughts about this you have any
worries or if you even care if you just
live in destiny but i got to get these
two as well um thoughts on all of that
craziness that's happened
i just want to see what happens i don't
like to like overreact or not even
overreact to me that's a bad word but
i'm sorry you have nuance on the
internet get too crazy first thank you
i want to see what happens i i want to
see what plays out a little bit and then
then i'll i'll have some comments on it
for sure well she's very reserved that's
right travis
yeah i've been i was i got a chance to
speak to him about it
oh my god i have so many thoughts about
this guys
um
yeah obviously i do
um
i
obviously like i don't know i there's so
much there's so much to think about here
so the first thing is like on a personal
level which is that i really don't like
any activision blizzard games i'm just
going to say that like and all the games
don't appeal to me like i i you know
call of duty is like not my favorite
shooter as a franchise neither is
overwatch for that matter and then you
know diablo i liked i guess i liked the
old ones and i was a kid diablo too but
diablo 3 didn't really do it for me and
i i don't i would be surprised if diablo
4 does um and then you know just like
looking at their library of games like
the one i've probably
had the most fun playing as like candy
crush
i can proudly say i have never played
candy crush
you know i i played i played it once and
once you play candy crush once man it's
hard to not play it a hundred times but
uh yeah it's it's not really my it's not
it's never been my favorite company i
know some people absolutely love it but
like world of warcraft is another
example where like i've put a lot of
time in the world of warcraft and i have
enjoyed almost none of my time like i
just it's one of those games like i just
sort of played it's like my monkey paw i
played it out of like devotion to my
friends that really liked it and i was
just like god this is just not
for me
um so
that's the personal one is that when i
saw the news i was like holy crap but
also on the other hand i was like does
this really like affect me personally i
guess the way it affects me is now i
won't have to buy the call of duty games
every year right because i do buy those
so now it'll just be on game pass so
that that's like the cool part but um so
there was that part of it like the
personal part the other part of it is
that like
consolidation in the industry is a
problem
definitely
um but i don't know if activision
blizzard is that big of an issue one
because
their company was
has been in a lot of trouble recently
and i view this as microsoft buying low
right which is what you do if somebody
if you have an opportunity to buy a
company like activision blizzard for
like half the price pennies on the
dollar because of their yeah because of
their current positioning like you do it
and the other part of it is that
apparently according to reports
activision blizzard approached microsoft
about it so they like recognized that
they were in trouble and then it was
time to get out right and to find a
culture that was going to help them so i
think uh
at and then the other part of is that
consolidation on a large scale is bad
but i actually think the games industry
is pretty healthy
and usually when a company gets acquired
all the people that work for this
company those companies if they don't
want to keep doing it if they want to go
and
build their own company they do that and
the
games industry is healthy enough to
where new companies are popping up all
the time and are successful and a lot of
these companies are made by the same
people that ran other companies that got
acquired by larger companies and so i
kind of view it as like a it's just like
part of the cycle right company starts
it gets big enough it gets acquired and
then the people who
succeeded they get a big exit and then
they leave and then they go start
another company and hopefully they they
innovate and keep doing that um so
i kind of um
i kind of i'm less worried about that
part of it for me it's more
activision blues are just such a huge
pillar of the industry and i cannot
fathom that being an xbox platform i
just i can't i can't i can't break bring
myself to think of
world of warcraft as an xbox game it is
weird right like how long how long is it
going to be how long is it going to be
before they add achievements to wow i
think about that that's just in my brain
now they're going to have achievements
in a while and you know they're going to
because every other franchise that
they've acquired they added achievements
to the games before they even finished
the acquisitions officially they did it
with like minecraft and stuff so i bet
you world of warcraft gets achievements
like before the official close even like
i think it's going to be like soon so
yeah there's just like
i'm still processing it
like it's it's so it's so colossal of a
shift in the industry like i i just
don't even know what the future's gonna
look like but it's crazy man it's crazy
they were like one of the biggest
companies what about you man
unbelievable so many thoughts i'll try
to super condense because i'll go on too
long you're gonna have you're gonna have
an eight-hour podcast on sunday
yeah sunday you already know look this
stuff
oh my god yeah oh it's gonna be you know
he's gonna be nuts with the king and the
acquired king i gotta watch it's gonna
be crazy so yeah you know on a personal
level i'm with trav like at old school
activation i used to like and i used to
like a lot of the stuff they acquired
but
you know honestly the only reason i was
really over there was destiny during the
time of the battle net days and um you
know for me
i actually think about the other aspects
of the deal it's just colossal and the
other aspect of deal obviously king the
mobile aspect and honestly the pc space
is what really encourages me because at
the end of the day you know microsoft's
kind of tread their foot in there but
they really i would say honestly don't
have the respect of the pc community the
hardware pc community and i feel that
that aspect can really get rejuvenated
if they do a rebranding and we know
about this i always always felt destiny
played way better on battlefield game
pass on battle net is that what you're
leading to
right like if they just did a re-brand
and say hey you guys got the better
infrastructure as far as the games um
you know i used to be call of duty
hardcore when it first came out you know
the 60 frames and innovative stuff i've
been cooled off but it is
massive right and all i will say to the
people you know i know there's a lot of
consolidation talk monopoly talk
anti-trust lawyer talk i will say this
to me i look at this thing is if they
continue to do moves like this every
year then it's like okay my eyebrows
raised but the way i look at it is
what's the alternative you have uh
activision which discrimination
sexual misconduct a leader who let's be
honest is going to get a golden
parachute on the way out but at the end
of the day i feel it's better for the
health of the studios and i'm pro dev so
i want games to continue to exist i want
studios to continue to exist so i i will
take microsoft any day of the week over
what was going there but it's up to
microsoft to still prove that they're
truly changing the culture
of that and it's not just a money thing
and they're going to be the the
hourglass is good i mean the eyes is
going to be on them so it's up to them
and so far everything sounds nice but
people want to know so that's what i
think about it initially yeah i've seen
la carte to that point about the golden
parachute i've seen a lot of talk about
like
how this is like the system working
wrong because bobby's probably gonna get
kicked out and make a lot of money
rewarding the way i see it though is
like this is like working as intended
right because
a bad actor got to the point where you
know his stock fell so low that he had
to sell his company right now he's
effectively having to give up everything
he did yeah
sure sure obviously nobody wants to see
that guy get richer but it is his
company right he did build activision
from the ground up and and deserves the
payout presumably but uh he's sort of
leaving in disgrace right and
now his company gets to get run by
people that are probably going to be
better uh uh caretakers of of that that
company so i feel like this is like the
best outcome we could have asked for
it's like almost the perfect solution
like i think like it's like all right
he's not in charge anymore and yeah it's
like i mean you see
you just see the culture of what xbox is
trying to do for consumers for gaming
they've done a lot of things you saw
like the diversity of the heads of all
of their departments that they've got it
was the full like org chart that they
showed i mean between like half female
for one which is like probably unheard
of most places and then just the
diversity that they've got in their
leadership already
they're not gonna let this stuff happen
let's try not to curse they're not gonna
let the stuff happen
because like from the top down that
stuff's gonna change hopefully and
that's the thing and that's why you said
you wanna see the change but i think as
you said also for the devs it's big
because there's a lot of people who
we've talked about it before it's like
these people are so ecstatic to get a
job in the industry anywhere
so the fact that they got on at one of
the activision companies whether it be
high moon vicarious visions we've had
experience with those in destiny oh yeah
oh yeah we were we're two years removed
from heading back to xbox like bungie's
like you got that part too but it's just
a whole lot of people working at places
building games that they are very
passionate about and finally it's to a
point where
if microsoft is able to say hey here's
the bag of cash to run your company yeah
you still got a report through us but we
want this to be run well we want to
build up these ips that we've got maybe
pull some of these ips that people
forgot about out of the closet they have
more money than basically any other
company to do that with and again it's
like while they are huge whether the
implications of if call of duty is ever
you know exclusive to xbox
there are very few people who could do
what xbox like microsoft did to a
company that large
and if anybody is going to do it i think
i am happy to see that one the
exclusivity talks are what people worry
about and things like that
is like the infrastructure of battle.net
that one will be interesting to see how
that goes for pc because i mean cog i
think we've joked about before it's like
or at least i've heard you and maddie
talk about like pc ports on microsoft
not so great
there are some buggy issues there and
you're like oh it's totally fine on
console but on pc you're like the thing
that's got more power runs it worse why
like
and again but battle net is like that is
their bread and butter as pc and they
live there so
i think there's a lot of things we don't
know
um it's just weird to think that every
time somebody also yeah mobile is
massive
absolutely massive between xcloud and
now kings like trying to get into mobile
forever forever yeah so it was like they
they got a lot bigger again as you said
travis the consolidation part is
somewhat worrisome because their weight
in the industry now they are a
juggernaut in the industry nobody is
even remotely close to their size now
like the number of studios well they're
number three they're number three i mean
even
the power of game pass a third of the
platform like tencent yeah they have
their hands and stuff sony doesn't still
have the by revenue but it's like
they're still just the weight of what
they can do now i'm just very curious to
watch it's like they are
they're the you know 800 pound girl in
the room
the ante
yeah the antitrust thing blows my mind i
i don't understand people that think
that microsoft is close to becoming
monopoly because like the the game space
is so competitive like they're not just
competing with playstation and sony
apple and nintendo and tencent but
they're also competing with google and
amazon and like
all the mobile space and i i like if you
if you think microsoft is a monopoly
like i have so many questions for you
about like like what you now the
the argument i have heard is that
they're worried that microsoft will
become a monopoly when it comes to
subscription services right right like
if if game pass just becomes the only
subscription service out there but even
then
dude netflix is making games
you know what i mean like
they're they're i just
yeah i think i think this is the easiest
slam dunk ever for microsoft to get this
past like an anti-trust
like uh look because like
there's just the more you think about it
the more you're like god damn like this
is a very competitive industry like and
it's getting more competitive all the
time absolutely
i'm really not worried about that part
of it the last point i'll say is i do
like the idea hopefully it looks like he
made a filmmaker comment and reference
too because as destiny fans one thing
that bungie was very frustrated was and
even luke smith and those guys outspoke
like hey we're not happy with the sales
of forespoken even though i mean
forsaken even though um you know it did
well and we remember the frustration
with um one them activision wanting a
destiny too
and then having to kind of fight and say
okay we'll make rise of vine but we
really want you to make this dressing
dude like they wanted to
annualize but continue to pump out
sequels and we're seeing with the call
of duty thing you know every studio in
the building kind of like forced to pump
out call of duty games and i i would
hope you know the culture changes in
some of those uh studios get a chance to
make other games so that you know i feel
it's more healthy for the industry that
something is not always annualized all
the time but we will see
yeah i just had to touch on it it was
too big i've seen a lot of twitter stuff
going around so there's no way we can't
talk about it but it was just one of
those you know it's the
yeah you can't not so it's crazy
yeah no absolutely um but yeah we got a
couple teasers on twitter with regards
to which queen if you guys haven't seen
them yet definitely go check them out
you know save the light and that type of
stuff we've seen
but the twab was uh
they were they were teasing us this week
with the twab topics you know a couple
of them you had
gunsmith materials you guys can spend
those we'll get to that
couple other things uh but they also did
say the topics that they're going to be
covering in the next few weeks not in
any specific order
vanguard reputation probably going to be
similar to the other reputations
we've got gambit reworks i know
azdacross's vault is scared
weapon crafting that's the one
everybody's waiting for because they
haven't mentioned the orbs of light
which we talked about last week and all
that fun and i'm thinking that's going
to go with crafting they won't give us a
date
void 3.0 which is going to be huge
that's going to be the full class rework
but those are the main topics we have
coming plus patch notes in sandbox and
you guys know we'll dive deep into
whatever's going to change to keep up
with void 3.0 but this week we've got
power levels gunsmith reputations some
exotic changes
and blues
so to get started we'll cover the first
thing power level which i have done this
for those of you guys who play destiny
all the time
you understand how the power leveling
works
i literally have made for the past
four five six seasons now
guides of how to level
and my videos don't my videos are tend
to be on the smaller side like lately
i've had a lot of activity thank you
guys for that one these are like my one
big ass video for the season usually
outside of some other like crazy guide
or something
like 150 000 views for me is pretty damn
substantial um and this happens every
time so again it's in here in front of
us and i guarantee you're gonna get
questions but the floor
everything you own every character every
piece of gear in the vault everything is
going to be bumped up to 1350 when you
log in at which queen
so right now 1330 is your max gear score
everything's 13.50 for ev for everybody
starting in the same place so it doesn't
matter if you grinded pinnacles doesn't
matter
so that's a thing but you can deal with
that if you want to
then the soft cap as you play through do
anything we're going to go to 1500 so
you're 150 levels
powerful cap is 1550 pinnacle cap is
1560. um same thing pinnacles is through
your in-game stuff powerful is the three
powerful engrams
all of those are pretty standard is this
surprising to any of you the 550
basically it's a 200 power level 210 by
the time you get done but like the the
starting's even higher than anybody i
don't know if that's anything they've
ever done before i just didn't know if
you guys had thoughts kind of seems run
of the mill anybody have an opinion
about this
thought let's get the vixen
bringing everybody up to 13.50 yeah
um i think it's actually great i think
that a lot of people who have taken
breaks
they
can see that and
because and and i see that i see that
with my friends that haven't played with
a long time because i mean when we're in
it whenever we miss a couple of weeks
when it's a new season you kind of feel
behind
if you miss you know the first three
weeks in a season you are going to feel
like oh my gosh i need to catch up you
know
so if you've taken this huge break and
you know how destiny is it's just kind
of overwhelming to even come back so i
feel like pulling everybody up
everybody's 13.50 it does make you know
people who haven't been around it's like
well hey i can jump back in you know i
don't have to like start all the way at
the beginning i can jump in
running you know and just playing and
enjoying it and i do like that aspect
about that for sure
yeah agreed i mean power level doesn't
really bother me i want a power level as
fast as i can to do very specific things
you know what i mean like i want to get
into gms you know i want to get into
a day one you know raid and stuff like
that so
i mean it really doesn't bother me i
think it's nice
cool yeah i mean i'll jump in
i agree i think that this is you know
obviously we've we've had our issues
with the way destiny on boards do lights
or we've we've talked about that at
nauseam but i do think it's one of those
situations where they have to recognize
a new expansion many people have not
played have gone away surprisingly their
engagement is still pretty high for a
quote-unquote dead season for the
hardcore right but the engagement is
still very high but um yeah i think it's
part of the marketing blitz you you get
all the new players to say hey day one i
can play with my hardcore friends and
like vixen said eloquently like they
don't feel left out because that's a lot
of what i get from what i call like you
know casual people that observe from the
outside
they like destiny but they're like i
don't know if i can commit but okay
we'll be on the same level at the start
of the expansion then yeah that that
incentivizes them to say okay you know
what i'll fire this up i'll rock with
you but um yeah i think this kind of
run-of-the-mill stuff i i wasn't too
surprised by this to be honest so
travis anything or just good to go
yeah i thought it was a pleasant
surprise uh actually my girlfriend and i
we were trying to play the new witch
queen expansion together but she's not
high enough level to do it just because
she hasn't put a lot of time into it
this past season so this is good news
for us like we're gonna get to be
roughly the same power level going into
this and uh
you know i'll still dab on her with all
my cool weapons
at least makes it so that we can play
together and also like i have a lot of
friends that go in and out of destiny i
have like casual friends and so this is
good for them because it's like okay
well you don't have to spend like hours
and hours leveling up before you can
even play the expansion you just you
sort of get to go into it so only issue
is it's no longer going to be on game
pass which like that's how a lot of my
friends were getting yeah
it's also going to be really weird you
buy the witch queen and you don't own
beyond light because you had it on game
pass and then they take it away
i experienced that i have so many
questions about how that's gonna work
that's weird
[Music]
yeah i was like for me i'm kind of the
same i was like the floor i think it's
the first time they've bumped the floor
above the ceiling that we've ever had
for gear score but it does just
basically draw a line and everybody
starts in the same place so i mean it's
good for that everybody kind of jumps in
the same it's just kind of gonna be an
even starting point it is i mean but
other than that i figured i was like 200
power like 200 levels as usual
um pretty standard stuff so far it's
like it unfortunately
also means that the leveling is
basically the same thing we've been
doing
do your eight bounties for your four
winners go do your three and the
playlist activities like you'll and now
you're gonna have less seasonal activity
so most of that stuff
and i say unfortunately because that's
just one of those things we all have put
our time in grinding and it does
it's getting a little long in the tooth
as well and i don't know if i i didn't
even expect major changes it would have
been nice to see a surprise
it sounds very straightforward of what
we've had before so
leveling seems to be the same at some
point maybe we'll get something and
we'll kind of touch on that here in a
second as we get into the next topic of
blues
i'm going last on this one by the way so
you guys can go first and we'll see if
it touches he's got thoughts he got hey
i'm claiming it calling it now
it's not that big of a deal this is kind
of one of those um so in the witch queen
blue
rare rewards will stop dropping from
playlist activities crucible strikes
gambit etc once players have reached
soft cap players above the soft cap 1500
and witch queen will instead see
slightly increased chance at legendary
rewards or legendary shards blue weapons
and armors will continue to drop from
enemies and chests while playing destiny
2 but we hope that this will reduce the
need for players to manage their
inventories and reduce the frequency of
visits to the postmaster
we have some work ahead of us when it
comes to the rarity as a subject in
destiny 2. while blue gear helps players
increase their power early in the game
we want to look at their place in the
overall game we aren't expecting any
major changes in the next few seasons so
i'm guessing not nothing until lightfall
but we will spend some time behind the
scenes thinking about the future of rare
drops all up
so what do you guys think because i mean
it's one of those things you see in the
community is like people really get
tired of blues tassie's been on here
i've said i mean
a lot of people have said it there's
probably a bungee please that covered
this at some point so who wants to take
this one first
anybody can stiffer for this one
i mean we've probably all lost
plenty and plenty of golf balls because
of blues
i
hate it no i have
i have probably lost more golf balls
than some people might ever earn
because of blues because i'm just like
doing so many like just gms and having
them stacked in your postmaster because
you can that 10
that they give you
has to go around to all your characters
right like they they share in that 10.
and
go ahead
i was gonna say could it be that you're
using the postmaster incorrectly oh here
we go oh absolutely it's a beautiful
expanded storage space yeah it's it's
yeah oh my gosh i've been playing since
my vault is a disaster i have three sons
of the past i don't even need one of
them but i have them one in every color
because
i'm nostalgic i don't know why i don't
know why i can't give up certain things
i don't know why people can't have
i don't have a lot
i have my own nostalgic items
that have certain pieces but i don't
have the ark the solar and the void
of the raindrops because you can't get
those anymore and that's fine like those
i've those i've parted my ways with my
my go figure my sniper from my biggest
like i have certain ones but i've gotten
rid of a lot yeah
so nope not had to go figure it
it's crazy to me
that we're talking about how to fix the
problem
because the real the real problem you
want to fix sarah is
you want to be able to carry more stuff
is like that's basically it right and
the way that we're fixing that the way
we're fixing that is oh well we want to
be able to store more stuff in the
postmaster and in order to be able to
store more stuff in the postmaster it
means that we need to not have items
disappear by picking up blues and so now
we're at this point where we're like
three
steps removed from solving the problem
we're actually trying to solve and now
we're focused on removing blues from the
game to accomplish this thing that
accomplishes this thing that
accomplishes the thing we actually want
to do so couldn't they just remove the
10 cap on golf balls and like otherwise
super annoying like like they could just
do that and it would totally be the
easier they feel like change the digit
now it's 25 450
there's no way currency capacities have
to be that difficult to program
i'm not not enough right
i refuse to believe that they could only
have
10 golf balls on on your account
and that's it like i just i just do not
believe it because i've seen how much
they can fit into eververse that menu is
immaculate it's got hundreds of options
and they're all available at all times
and it's like it's it works so perfectly
if my
inventory could work half as well
as the eververse menu works then
you know i just don't it's [ __ ]
i'm saying that the priorities of the
eververse database have uh superseded
the the player experience is that what
you were flying sir uh
i'm i'm implying that uh if if uh if if
bungie is a is a human if we're
personifying bungie and he's going out
for the night right
he's got his he's he's got his nice uh
his nice shirt on and he's got his
bluetooth
stuff this is going somewhere let's go
spongy going out for the night i'm
telling you
that his highest stat in terms of
getting a date that night is his wallet
that's where he's putting most of his
priorities that's all i'm gonna say
that's like that's bungie's move because
they go out and they go hey here's my
bank statement that's
i i do think that that
like it's so funny that destiny players
are so close to the problem that they
can't see what the real problem is like
everybody's talking about vault space
vault space vault space and the real
problem that they have is that they want
the collection game that they're playing
to actually let them collect things well
there's this thing called the
collections tab that's supposed to do
that and it doesn't talk about that yeah
right the solution that we've come up
with oh we need vault space it's like
vault space isn't really the problem
right the postmaster and blues aren't
really the problem it's just our way of
coming up with a solution for bungie
because they insist on creating this
problem for us for god knows what reason
sure maybe there's technical issues i
don't know okay i would have there's no
there's a cap on strange coins there's
no reason for that
oh god oh no i'm sorry there is a reason
to force you to go oh no you've played
too many strikes now you got to go over
here make sure and spin those so you go
it's literally to make you
cog how can i [ __ ] how can i have tens
of thousands
weapon parts legendary shards
weapons all these useless slots and then
i could only have 21
keys for dares of attorney oh that was
so glaring
though because everybody's been tweeting
that yeah about the weapon that is so
perfect
because they've literally been tweeting
their
gunsmith materials over here everybody
this week is just like look how many
look how many
and
i mean let's just ask them let's just
ask them i'm going to start asking bunji
then everybody start asking bungie just
give us some more good give us a reason
why are golf balls
he's the reason because you don't want
people to be able to hoard golf balls
yes it's for sure 100 percent i'm
recording them
through
master working exotics and stashing them
in my vault so i am hoarding them
prisms
later oh my god you're laundering golf
balls you're laundering golf balls
through prisms
[Laughter]
oh my god
you have a problem oh no i don't want to
run out oh no dude you're smuggling
my destiny
with my ships no i know i know when i
max my glimmer and buy ships and then
sell them back when i'm poor glimmer
yeah it's like it's like you've got pure
cocaine and you're diluting it you know
breaking it out so you can get bigger
batches that's what that's what
and then she's towing the giant
planet-sized santa bag of infinite
supplies behind her
now now we know that the drifter's rock
is a crack rock i think we've discovered
that
we haven't gone all the way off
thank you travis
do you have any opinions about blues and
power levels and artificial developer
limits and armchair discussions
let's hear them
it's a quality of life change yeah okay
you know on on a small it's a
half step right towards what the real
issue is and the real issue is
the vault space problem which is really
compounded by the fact what i agree with
travis is saying with the collection
problem if the collections work as
intended right we would just pull from
collections but the problem i think the
real issue from a developer standpoint
is what for whatever reason they are
unable to
solve the problem of pulling random
roles from collection when destiny 2 was
first created we were in a static role
database
right so i am not going to try to
pretend that i know how to do that now
this is where i'm with you all though i
know i can call be corporate [ __ ] fine
i'll be corporate [ __ ] today but
this is where i'm with y'all where i'm
with y'all
is the artificial
limit and scarcity
of
high end materials for end game content
i will not fight you guys with that we
all know the golf balls the shards and
i'm with y'all on the prioritization of
eververse which tess is fine she doesn't
have any problem she's updating her
database she's got pages about pages up
on pages of ornaments for you
she's got emotes all day you you can
even access her in space you don't even
got to go to the tower
she got you covered she's got that
direct access straight through
you you got her you got the direct line
that's what i need so i am with you on
that and we all know that rarity is this
manufactured kind of scarcity kind of
thing and we start it all started from
glimmer caps and you know all that stuff
that we we hate and they they've got to
do a better job with it but with this
yeah this is a half step on a quality
life thing i totally understand the eye
rolls i totally get it and it's funny
last thing i'll say
i started playing um
outriders
this week because they had the new
horizon i mean um expeditions
and i'm just like
man management is so much easier dude
you got it right like out of the gate
like
operators writers had some technical
issues you couldn't play for a month
dude i get that but i will definitely
tell you for a game that looked around
it was like what can we do right they
got a lot when they worked they got they
worked caveats
but when it worked yeah actually like
it'll and then they were like transmog
easiest transmog system ever i did the
trans mall yeah i did the transmog this
we did this week you know i was like wow
it's one button and all my blues in it
like it was just oh this is awesome like
i can prioritize so again i i'm with
y'all on that part for sure yeah my
not big of a rant or anything it's just
like it's
i watch tassie's video on it just kind
of watched datto's video on it i was
like going to run an errand real quick
and
it's it's the half step it's not what we
wanted because now granted technical
limitation is what it probably is 100
probably will give them that but again
it's like why
is it
once you hit 1500 and unless there's
some i would say it's
like a little thing maybe for like new
players in case they don't have us quite
as many options maybe for a little while
but like once you're 1500 the only gear
that's helping you is legendary anyway
so like if you hit 1500 i do not need to
be in a raid and see a blue drop from a
guy
no reason for that so the fact that it's
like crucible strikes gambit you can't
throw like raids dungeons masters can't
that be of just a bigger list maybe i
don't know it was just
it's a weird place where sometimes it
does but the first time i see a blue
dropping raid i'm like yep you're not
supposed to be there it's just one of
those weird ones where it's like it's
i've joked about this before it hints my
worry of weapon crafting until i see it
i don't know it's the it's the half step
we keep getting it's we're part way
there it's kind of what we wanted but
yeah you have limited capacities but
infinite eververse you have blues that
don't drop in playlist activities but
you're going to see one drop from a raid
boss it's just
it is yeah you know it's not quite there
that was more it than anything so it's
not like a big one but it was just
something
yeah last point is it's it's
demoralizing kind of what vixen said
especially to even see it in any high
end content right it's just
disrespectful to the amount of
engagement and effort and let's be real
what was the classic
remember the curse of osiris dream
failure what was it two tokens
what was the joke that was like
literally they were laughed out the room
or mostly when they were most rewarding
public public event ever and you're like
two two tokens in a blue
yeah yeah yeah so one would think this
that technically wasn't inaccurate
though is the messed up thing about that
that was the most rewarding publication
it was the step up from one token in a
blue
yeah yeah it was basically one blue yeah
that was the previous reward not a whole
bunch
yeah anyway
off of the little baby rant there's
definitely some positivity in this swab
though so we got to talk about that as
well gunsmith reputation banshee's
getting a new reputation system
uh basically the way zavala and shaq's
have had theirs before they are removing
gunsmith um
materials
and weapon telemetries they are going to
be gone from your inventory on february
22nd
spend them now
don't save them they will do you zero
good in weapon crafting they're gone
um
that being said players will now earn i
hate when they do this i know it is kind
of yeah so if you have like can we talk
about this for a second yeah go get good
good i know you go on track i hate when
they the way that the way that they get
rid of currencies is terrible because
they they put it all on you they're like
hey we made this mistake currency that
we're going to get weapon telemetry is
our job you want to
yeah it's like if you want to benefit at
all
you need to get go in the game and hold
x for two hours that's what we're gonna
make you do
yeah why are you making me do chores
because you're deciding you know what i
mean like that's like if uh
if they were if you know they they put
like the the penny out of print and so
you had to bring in all of your pennies
and have them converted you know they
have me go to like stall
cash in my boxes
of change how much did i get that's fine
i only got 26 what the hell that was a
huge box
is more fun than what they make you do
in destiny she's right yeah this one
because at least it's like a little game
you get to see all the money slide down
maybe that's what they need maybe they
just need a more fun way it looks like a
slot machine
yes they got to make it more of a show
come on turn it into pachinko
already
the game show the weird nays and
everything he's just gonna run the game
show that is turning in your currencies
uh but basically he's just gonna at
least make a fun way for me to a fun way
for me to lose all my money make like a
casino where gunsmith parts are the
currency and i just get to go and play
blackjack until i lose all of my
currency you know if i gotta lose it all
anyway at least make the experience fun
to not just hold x and then the messed
up thing is once you get rid of all of
your weapon parts then you have a ton of
weapons you don't want that you have to
disagree yeah so you have to do like two
steps yeah of destroying things you
don't want especially if you're such a
way if you're you know bursting at the
seams like a couple of us are you're
gonna be like all right let me turn in
10 bust over 10. turn in 10 break down
10. turn into 10 break down 10 just to
make sure it's like did i get a good
roll no
it's not a lot of them yeah i guess um
but i mean he's so much home it's he's
going to get basically a system i was
going to ask you guys though players
will now earn reputation rank progress
with banshee when dismantling legendary
and exotic weapons and armor
or by completing daily gunsmith bounties
can somebody confirm maybe chat knows
this as well when you do bounties for
like shacks or zavala you don't get
reputation from that it's typically just
completing the activities correct
somebody may know this
believe so i can't remember off top uh
chat help us
chat
because i feel like you get like xp
for like your normal season pass and
you'll get but you don't get reputation
correct okay yeah you don't get
reputation by doing bounties which kind
of bugs me i'll be honest like if i do a
bounty for shacks and i don't get
reputation for shacks yeah that's like
that's weird it was weird you were
locked into only the playlist yeah
because
they don't want people to be able to
blow through the grind in one day by
doing uh
back to this artificial limitations once
again here we are yeah so i just i
wanted to check to see if i was crazy
because when i saw that i was like
that's a good thing that bounty's helped
that but you have to do something for
him because you don't have a choice but
it's like
breaking down
breaking i love how it's like when
dismantling legendary weapons armor i'm
like all right you break those down when
dismantling exotic weapons or armor it's
like yeah we just do that all the time
all the time no big deal it's fine
uh mod components also with regards to
banshee they're gone there are going to
be no more mod components so the stack
of
1200 or whatever that i have i can't
even do anything i can't turn them into
anything into anybody i love that i
can't even
can i buy one golf ball for a thousand
mod components come on give me give me
the horrible exchange rate just one time
nope yep those are going to be gone
agreed uh all mods will be 10 000
glimmer each
that's basically the cost
it's pretty pricey
uh also the currency exchange is going
to be moving to rahul
so the currencies of prisms
upgrade modules i think or upgrade
modules might stay but prisms and golf
balls those are why'd they have to give
it they have to go to rahul so you're
going to be spending some more time with
him i think why'd they give him the job
he's like the one you least want to
interact with because
the spider spider's out he's
tangled shore got taken over by the
darkness so he's gone
um
but the
actual the good thing is banshee and 801
who currently have two mods in their
rotation will now have four because
there's more spots for it so if you're
trying to build out your mod collection
it's gonna be easier because you don't
have to farm for mod components just
gonna be glimmer and then if you're
looking to if you're a newer player
trying to get all the mods it should be
easier because you're gonna have a set
of like eight on rotation a day so it
should go pretty quick if you have the
glimmer so i think that's a good thing
rahul will also be taking your
umbrella engrams
so if you wanna like right now when you
take your umbrella to an umbrella
decoder just anything in the world loot
pool that's going to be real cool but if
you want to do a focus like we do the
prismatic recaster that will be done at
the seasonal vendors whoever goes into
the helm in the
future um
yeah i like that so that's a lot of the
things like that's nice yeah highlights
and those changes you need you're like
yes quality of life fist pumps anything
anything in there
just the umbrellas because you know i
felt that was just a forced extra step
for the helm now i understand we can't
use the prismatic whatever thing to to
do the weapons the seasonal weapon
change i get that you give the helm that
purpose but i always felt it was
annoying that i'm sitting in the tower
and these umbrals do nothing and i i'm
forced to go there like i always thought
that was an
added extra unnecessary step
i've deleted so many umbrellas just
because i couldn't
you know i had other people in my fire
team or whatever i didn't you know so i
just like oh just delete them just to
make it
like hold on guys we gotta go to the
hospital
i can't pick them in ingrams
they're all purple
what else we got uh so the next one is a
bigger change covered some of this in my
prep video so as of february 22nd
harbinger and press exotic missions will
no longer be accessible i hope they
bring them back in the game and like
legacy or something they're too good but
they are leaving for now especially
precedent going into that content vault
yeah they're going to that content vault
for that little rehash yeah
uh therefore instead of adding these
items to the monument of lost lights
it's where you can go buy exotics they
wanted to preserve the ability for
players to still get random roles and
everybody's kind of been wondering like
these are the only two exotics with
random roles how's that going to work
well
zerg just got a bit spicier
zur is now going to offer a unique role
every week for hawkmoon and deadman's
tale they don't get too excited and i'm
gonna tell you now you have five weeks
try and run these missions five more
times if you don't have the role you
want because running a mission once a
week is cheaper than what you're gonna
have to pay
because it's gonna cost you one golf
ball you've only got ten max remember
you're capped out on those sorry
salt in the open wound there one exotic
cipher that's the quest that you can get
from
zur which takes you like 21 strikes or
something to do it's i haven't actually
done that quest i just know it looks
like it's long 125 000 glimmer so
literally half your capacity and 200
legendary shards
damn so a cog you got you got a reaction
over there
zara is out here man what's going on
with these exchanges i mean the spider's
gone somebody's got to be like sitting
on all the money right
like it isn't decipher correct me if i'm
wrong y'all doesn't decipher has a one
carry cap you can't even like carry more
than one
guys this is why we were talking about
market consolidation is so bad because
without competition zur is going to be
raking us over the coals you know
spiders bringing it full circles
without him what are we supposed to do i
was like bro what's the price of spin
metal today what's going on it's
fighting this like it's 10 000 glimmer
for one that's the current exchange
right you're like good god bro
sir got this horse and he don't know how
to act right now and i i feel away right
now
sir really got hollywood oh that's real
quick
a short and a cipher bro wow okay he's
right he's riding that pony and he needs
he needs uh
he needs some currency to pay for that
addiction
clearly
this game show is a lucrative business
yeah he's doing a lot of giveaways he's
got to pay for him on the back end
shout out to daisy he did he he ran that
entire game show on credit
he's got loan sharks after him he's got
a he's gonna make ends meet before
travis falls off the defense sarah
do you have like the god rules on these
do you want do you have anybody who
you're like helping run through this do
you also what do you feel about the
price um
that's pretty high i mean i've got
plenty of
plenty of stuff to break down for him
but i'm good on those two weapons um
but
yeah that is really high i was just
thinking about the exotic cipher because
i think
i
must have just acquired the ones that
i've had i think from the pass or
whatever i don't even know what that
would take to
i mean that's a one exotic cipher on the
season pass right
is that right you get one of those
that sounds about right i think yeah
yeah i still get the notification that i
can't carry two because i haven't used
the one yeah me too it was just annoying
yeah i get it's so annoying i need to
actually when zur is here i need to do
that because i need to pull because you
can spin the 97 shards get exotic then
you can spin the exotic cipher and get
an exotic and then i could actually pick
up the one from the triumphs that i've
never done because one's always sitting
there so i actually need to remember to
do that
um
but yeah it's like for me like a golf
ball an exotic cipher that's a lot
between those two because you don't get
a lot the 200 shards the glitter you'll
get those back that's not as big but the
golf ball and the exotic cipher that's
why i'm like go for him now cause this
is not cheap now granted there's gonna
be like
four and a half months from now
everybody's gonna log in and be like
it's the god rule and that's gonna be
all over everybody's youtube video
preserve it's like go buy your dead
man's tail right now because it's got
four poland high caliber and whatever
else the god rules are but
until then apparently save this stuff up
yes
uh i will say a positive note though
catalysts
something we i because the missions are
straight up going away and you get your
catalyst inside of those missions
um all of the catalysts for hawkmoon
dead man's tail and ag receptor i was
wondering about that one as well those
are all going to go into playlist
activities strikes crucible gambit so
you'll be able to get those there i
guess ag receptor is just going to be
from the kiosk it's actually going in
there
and then the full list of catalysts
we're also
finally getting outbreak perfected
whisper the worm and fourth horseman i
actually didn't know wasn't there so
those are all going to be available from
your basic activities but it took
what is it 18 months to finally get
outbreak and whisper
into the game because i think they went
away when that season of arrivals when
the solar system got smaller right
because the missions went away
and then after that right we haven't
been able to get the catalyst for 18
months and now it's just like oh it's in
the playlist activities
i have a question why did it take 18
months to put it in the playlist
activities
it just seems like it could have been in
there a little sooner
fix it
i am really disappointed that they did
not put that air apparent catalyst in
there because that is the only one i do
not have
i didn't really mess with the guardian
games and that was the only way you
could get it and so
i was so excited i was like they're
putting catalyst in and then i looked
and i was like no you gotta wait for
that i'll know next year we gotta give
you a reason to come back in next year
yeah
yeah what about um
the
so they're they're they're doing this
because they're taking those events out
of the game right yep right the missions
are going away the activities
yep
talk about it yeah i feel like they i
feel like they could have turned
pressage into uh
like a dungeon like they could have just
added that to the dungeon playlist right
i feel like they need a dungeon playlist
at this point yeah so many people really
loved it
when i played that like live on stream i
was like
dude the sound the ambiance like the
whole thing is like i'm in aliens i'm
literally in the movie right now they
did such a good job with that one and
again people are gonna miss out on can't
play whisper
can't play zero hour can't play pressage
yeah harbinger is kind of unique but it
doesn't still have like the the other
three i say are like bigger unique
missions harbinger like mostly just the
end of the boss fights
they could add to the strike playlist
yeah harbinger yeah it does feel like a
strike yeah it's just match game
legendary strength yeah it is like
because he has all the shields and
everything in there but outside of that
like the other three like go put those
into the legends playlist have those on
like a rotation one of the legends
missions this week you can run it and
get a pinnacle or something that feels
like
as these missions fall away
there's so many cool experiences like
what are the ones you talk about whisper
it's like my favorite video zero hour
like one of our previous guest mano did
like a thousand clears on zero hour but
it was like you had the timer you had
what was the stupid robot who chased you
down what was his name oh what was his
name
oh it wasn't trevor
trevor i was like nobody was gonna know
the first time you jumped
like the scream of trevor
god the panic of him just coming and not
knowing where the hole was to like just
get out of there
and then like
having somebody do a blind run through
and just listen to somebody experience
presage there's
they've made really cool experiences and
it's always sad to see them leave
especially for the work that i know like
the devs put in i would love to ask you
dev and be like hey here's this cool
thing you've even got the legends
category now
right how hard did you fight for that to
make it in there and it still didn't
make it yeah like that yeah like how
does it sound no no no
no i was just gonna say that um how do
they you made a good point just how do
they internally feel the creators of it
right
when it's a live service game and now
the the dcv exists
and your baby is going away like how do
they truly feel that that would be an
interesting guy i doubt i would get the
the on podcast if we'd have yeah that
would be the off record
but i mean even take this season now
like shattered realm
that's a really cool activity that all
three of us raved about because it was
like you had the metroidvania unlocking
stuff as you went through the weeks
again it's like a cool seasonal activity
and yeah this was a six month season but
if the delay wouldn't have been there
that still probably would have been the
same activity i would imagine and it's
like that cool activity gone like the
expunges and the out like over the stuff
that's done on the planet surfaces like
the overrides season of the worthy where
you're like hey this is just a public
event those
i don't think people are as attached to
but when you make an entire realm
i always hate to see those go
um yeah i agree i agree the effort the
memories i totally agree
the next topic
which is one of the better reasons why
we have this guest here she's been
patient waiting for this one i'm sure
uh the raid date is upon us we have the
official raid date raid time we do not
have the raid name
we just have the witch queen redacted
raid
raid date is going to be march 5th 10
a.m pacific so the launch of the
expansion will be the 22nd so you
literally have i think it's 10 days if
math works and days 10 days
yeah it's like same thing we had with
deep stone crypts and i think last wish
was the same with 10 days it's kind of
been that
uh last wish was last time it was
basically i think we had like three days
oh that was the terrible one oh yeah
yeah wasn't that the powerful hour
garden was ten that's right shadow keep
was ten okay garden garden was tempting
last wish was insane i do remember that
yeah that one was like four days that
one was way too quick yeah
yeah this is this is exactly what i
thought i was going to do because since
i'm reviewing
this game i'm going to have 10 days and
then i'll write my review or finish my
review the day
of the raid
assuming i can beat it yeah we'll have
additional details on contest bungee
rewards so you'll see what the jacket
looks like the shirt the m whatever
comes from it
until then get on those time off
requests so
as we have the raid sherpa in here i
want to hear
what is your prep for the raid miss
sarah what are your
how do you get ready for one and then
also what is your plan for those 10 days
is it all
let's let's hear what your world is
gonna look like in about five weeks
well
starting this week we are just going to
like hit the weekly bounties really hard
we do want to save up some xp
to try to to get as high as quickly of
course um
i'm sure they'll disable the artifact
for contest i mean that's not gonna
matter or whatever but still
you know to be able to run other things
and and get all our pinnacles done and
everything else would be nice to
have some highlight but so lots of lots
of bounties for that xp
and then
materials making sure that you do have
you know you want to be of light or
comfortable at that light but you need
to have some backup infusion material
you don't know what's going to be good
or what's going to be good for this
encounter that encounter it's important
to
to just have that extra infusion
material so that if they're like okay
it's going to be
you know this or that you can
put that in there and equip it and keep
going and you're not like oh this is the
only thing i can run you know
so you definitely don't want that just
have enough materials glimmer
get in there
work with your team help each other you
know do that do that prep work do that
your pinnacles and stuff when it comes
time so that everybody's everybody's
helping each other and getting up as
quickly as possible
yeah yep i agree i agree i think it's uh
homework season
yeah you know the routine your prep now
you know we know the routine y'all you
know you get your bounties you know i've
seen eve put the tweet out you know he's
getting this week he's got his iron
banner ones done and stuff like that you
know trav is going to be in the mode in
the zone you know what i mean with the
review you know i'm going to be
basically what i did is you know the
last weeks just make sure i did my you
know sandbox optimal things you know
catalyst done and arborless stuff and
you know all the things that because we
know the meta is going to shift
and we're just getting ready but this
for the raid i love
you know that space that just give
people the space i love saturday right i
mean that's what it is
yeah that thank god saturday yeah so
much better for everybody so much better
they've got record engagement we
remember you know what was it was it
what was it was it fault or what was the
one before was it the one before one
they when did they do the scene
o'clock i think because it has the most
things
that had the most engagement and clears
and stuff that they had before i feel
like yes
yeah you're absolutely right it was
crypt i remember how pleasant that was
you know for the most part you know and
give people time you know we we got the
the you know the caps we know what the
numbers are you give people enough time
we don't have to destroy ourselves for
two three days with no sleep and oh my
gosh
like then you get angry you get
frustrated every single drop that
doesn't go your way
you know it was it was pain we we've all
survived those days so it's good to see
them you know on this side and the last
point for me is contest mode please
please please please after it happens
let's let's leave it around for those
who still want it and let's reward those
who want to engage in that type of
activity because we know what's going to
happen
once that raid is beat and they take it
off oh it's gonna start let the melting
begin seriously it does go so fast
and you're out of here
we know what's gonna happen so please
bunji the community wants this really
bad
give them that challenge and reward them
maybe put a unique reward put something
dude give someone a live or something
you know it was like the same way they
did you know you have the 24-hour emblem
make it unique totally get it
yeah but then if you want to go do it on
contests later but and you know you you
could get i don't even know if you could
get both or you just automatically get
both but to get that emblem you got to
do it in 24 hours do something different
to like have the contest be at least
worth the challenge and it also would
help people for like what would people
be doing right now if say deep stone
crypt was on
contest they would be practicing being
basically under leveled right now
because you actually could practice it
as opposed to
i can kind of equip some low stuff maybe
like it actually really kind of lets you
practice some of those difficult things
and here's a thought tribe might
appreciate this how about
increase the rage drop percentage of the
raid exclusive oh my
higher difficulty stuff how about that
cause there's a lot of guys still they
got vex eyes tomorrow
i think
i think and i i say this as a very very
biased person
who
beat deep stone crypt in the first 24
hour period during contest mode
i think if you beat it in contest mode
you should get the exotic
that's true i think they beat it that
first week you you're that or sorry that
first 24 hours i think you should get it
the fact that i beat it i beat deep
stone crypt in contest mode and then i
had people that hadn't beaten in a
contest mode get eyes of tomorrow right
away while i had to grind it for nine
months or however long it was like
that's
completely ridiculous to me
yeah so
i think i think that's a good because
then because then it would be on if you
could if you had a guaranteed drop if
you eat at 24 hours like people would be
trying way harder oh yeah to beat it be
like oh is this kind of a tough boss no
no we're in this thing until i pass out
at 2401.
oh we gonna do this yeah
but we know about the artificial
extension of fun
you know how they do or
rip destiny
in the back yeah i was like it's funny
you know what's funny is uh people
have
destin in particular had absolutely no
sympathy or empathy for anybody who is
grinding yeah that hard until it happens
to him yes i remember he was he was all
that way about anarchy because he had to
grind anarchy forever and then as soon
as it was my turn with eyes of tomorrow
he was just like bro whatever just like
keep playing until you get it
now that it's happening damn to max he's
like this is stupid and i'm like yeah
bro like that's how i felt like
yeah
we gotta let it do all right guys i'm
out for the night signing off i'll catch
you guys later when they see that exotic
drop
they done
yeah i got it that's right
what about you have you been lucky on
your grind for raid exotics or have you
had any long extended slogs for any
drops
i think my 1k
i think literally
though i was waiting on my 1k for my
ribbon spain
so wow it was like
wow
awful so that one i think it was
probably like 60 something runs of it
but
i mean i feel for everybody on the like
one of our clan mates i mean it was
three times a week it was 85
85 runs
and then he has gotten seven
vects
yes he died
with y'all like that got to stop
as much as i put the controversial tweet
out i know he's gonna come for me about
the engagement with the the rape drops
but
that yeah they cannot be yeah the
algorithm cannot reward someone who
already has the rate specific drop over
someone who's never gotten it like that
cannot happen and then maybe the
percentage like it almost feels like
it's like a one percent chance increase
every race like what is the actual
percentage probability of this algorithm
it's to be busted yeah and that's the
thing if you told me it's like hey if
you've got to do it 20 times if you do
it right 20 times you have like paid
your dues you know how to rate you've
done it enough whether it's like you
you're probably not going to get sherpa
20 times you're gonna have to step up
gonna have to play a part you're gonna
have to like learn the mechanics to an
extent
likely i would imagine to actually
guaranteed get there has to be a set
limit because when you're saying 60 80
no that's why honestly i have not gotten
for some of those is because
i tend to not rate that much but it's
like if that's the like i've experienced
the rate especially like vault i've done
most of it before
but it's like if if i could be one of
those unlucky ones and i'm like hey let
me do this and i could be still talking
to you guys i'm like i'm so tired of
this f raid i would be so pissed and
it's that is one of those i'm like until
there's a wall that i can't actually
know i can reach
it's just it's frustrating
to me fair enough fair enough
see [ __ ] is empathetic
to a point you're like i still want to
see you
you have to admit all right jokes a
little i know we'll move on there is a
fun
there is an envy fun
when that dragon
it's a little no fix it like
but you know what it is it's like but
that's because you were on the receiving
end of that of course you're not for it
i think cock's point is that there is
there is some fun to the idea of some
people having some people not having it
and i think that's the only reason that
bungie has allowed kind of this wild
west model to rule but there's there's
got to be a limit there's got to be a
moment where at some point it stops
being fun and it starts being like okay
screws what's that i'm sick of it it's
just sad it's just every week we i mean
because that's what we do you know after
we sherp everybody well like right now
we're just trying to help everybody you
know get their three three clears every
week try to get their vex and stuff and
it's sad
when you take the same people and it's
like is it there is it there i know
i just think the part is funny where is
the person who does the most work who's
sherpa and who's got everyone all
organized and then a lot of times it'd
be the person who's messing up who not
doing the experience the one they
brought with them yeah be like all right
everybody we're here to share let's get
everything done cool i'm running this
ain't cool you got it today all right
let's run this thing okay somebody else
got it like five months later
all right everybody if anybody gets it
i'm deleting your account like you lose
it at a point
they want to show up look guys is this
what's that what's the eyes of tomorrow
is this a good gun
is this good it's vex vex mythic class
you're like player six has left the game
yes all right guys go to bad team team
tomorrow oh my god i'm sorry all right
i
is saying that they should definitely be
rng like are you saying foreign that's
changed that had the 85 clears and now
he has seven vexes he's that's my guy
yeah if you enjoyed the grind of 70 then
you are a
different person than i am but more
powerful
final piece besides obviously always go
check out the art go check out the
videos of the week those are always fun
i just can't play them obviously no big
deal um quick clarification before we go
iron banner bounties will not be removed
at the end of the season there is one
more iron banner uh coming in the final
week of the season
and they did say like all the seasonal
bounties all the tangled shore bounties
those are all going away some of the
daily bounties from general activities
and destinations will be removed
depending on if the they're like kind of
reworking them so like some drifter
bounties some guns with the bounties are
getting taken away so if you are doing
bounty prep do a little review go look
up a video a guide i've got one but
apparently need some tweaks
but if you're going for iron banner
bounty they will not drop any higher
than 13.50 so if you open an iron banner
bounty
win witch queen you'll get something
but you will not get
high level stuff
they go to hustle so if you want to
grind out iron banner bounties so it
should be well i mean yeah no honestly
like for me i don't even care about the
level because you're gonna get so much
stuff if i get like one or two of the
new weapons i'll take it just because
like that's why i did him last time i
did him last week i was like i haven't
played my warlock i haven't played my
hunter i played all three characters all
the way through their bounty so it's
like i need to use these other two so i
worked through and i saved them and then
i saw this and i was like if nothing
else if i get one new iron banner weapon
it's something i have early so that's
the only reason right and a little bit
of xp if you're doing that you can
decide if bounty hoarding does anything
for you you could probably care to you
know care very little about it and you
will likely be very fine as well it just
depends on if you want a little
basically a little jump start that's it
i have five weeks not much else to do so
i am stocking up bounties
but if you have a whole bunch of other
stuff to do like 500 hours in be in um
dying light too for example you can
probably skip the bounty hoarding and
still be just fine
speaking of you travis you said you're
uh before the show started you said your
destiny grind kind of came to an end
what what happened yeah what was that
about
yeah so i told you guys last week that i
was unable to really play destiny 2
because i refused to give up my streak
in dares of eternity
well i started doing the math basically
i knew that i was going to get a dying
light code early this week so i was
doing the math on doing my five runs a
day and i realized that i was basically
like five or six hours of grinding away
which i could have done over the course
of like two weeks at my current pace i
was five or six hours of grinding away
from just being done so uh i i use
uh the the the
blessed martin luther king day uh where
you know we weren't working to grind
out that that's how i used my extra day
i i grinded it all out so i am
officially done with dares of eternity i
got the catalyst for uh the halo pistol
um and
basically i'm i'm done like i've
completed the only quest i haven't
completed
is the quest to get the exotic ship
that you get for doing the hawkmoon
quest where you gather the feathers
that's it like i i think i have i'm
gonna do that like this weekend but
other than that like i'm done i've
cleared out all my quests i've gotten
all the weapons that i need to get i
have every catalyst in the game
so
um i'm officially done
and now i can focus on other reviews i
got to review dying light 2 which is
going to apparently take me 500 hours uh
fml and then uh
and then i have to do crossfire x
yeah i've got a couple reviews uh here
uh but other than that um i'm feeling
pretty great because
there's nothing worse than having to
play destiny especially a repetitive
activity you aren't enjoying grind it
and grind it and grind it and then right
when which queen comes out you're
already like sick of it you know you're
already sick of destiny that breaks now
i'm gonna get to take like uh i'm gonna
get to take like a full month off since
trials is basically dead
because bungie stopped updating it a
while ago um
i uh
since that since that's the case i'm
sort of just not gonna play destiny in
this final month knowing that uh i'm
already prepared and i'm sure as ibontis
was saying they'll probably make us play
like two weeks before the expansion
comes out oh yeah you know there's got
to be like an ending to the the sabbath
story yeah i think you're muted yeah
yeah yeah yep yeah just the story drop
will probably happen
again if iron banner's the last week my
hunch is the story will be the week
before that
somebody was saying there was like some
in life
alignment
like of the moon or there's like a lunar
alignment there's something going on in
real life that we were
uh we i was streaming one day and
actually jar of we've had him in before
he actually mentioned that as something
they could like they wanted to mess with
like astral alignment and actually tie
it in with something real they could do
it on february 1st but again i still
think that would be like three weeks out
i'm still my money if i had to put my
money on would be the eighth so
lunar new year thank you
yep
enough so
that is most of it for the twab i think
that covers just about everything though
um
sarah i know you've been a little quiet
as we tend to uh probably talk a lot uh
but i wanted to ask you like what are
you gonna be are you mostly just
sherping at this point what are you
doing between now and
launch is there any checkboxes you
haven't done that you like
you got a couple skeletons you need to
clean up or what yeah a little bit i
like to you know how you'll have like
the europa like destination where you
have like 660 out of 60 or whatever it
is
well i'm trying to get all of that stuff
done so i need to just like get a little
bit more cabal gold and then finish up a
few things on my season of the hunt and
i just want to make sure that i get all
the triumphs done especially for the
things that are going away like
tangled shore stuff so
all that sort of you know and then of
course yeah we're we're really um trying
to trying to work in some divinity runs
at least like
to pick that up a little bit more try to
help people get their 1ks and then of
course the vex try to
try to help some people finish up some
raid titles things like that before
just
a lot of raiding before witch queen
nice nice salute that's really cool love
love what you're doing in that space and
you know i love what you said in
reference to you know yourself
how you felt you know it's kind of like
a really rough experience and you're
like you know what i'm not gonna let
anybody go do that i'm gonna give them a
positive experience for their first time
and it's really cool it's really cool
because the people are so many people
are intimidated
by rays and
yeah they don't want to mess up they
don't feel anybody wants to play with
them and run with them and um it's
really cool when you when you have that
community and everybody feels welcome
and it's cool to see them get that some
really cool gear for the first time and
you know
that's really the best part i mean just
to hear people just
freak out whenever they do get that
clear when they do
get their exotic they've been waiting
for but yeah
i mean you're right it's a lot of people
sometimes they're
they've just never even been in a party
with six people before
you know and they're nervous and they
don't want to mess up and they're scared
and it's like you don't have to worry
about that you're good nice
nice so it is nice yeah
i run with that i wanted to say that to
you it's it's not just me and
like i love coming out here and talking
to you guys and stuff but i just want to
make it clear that it is really like i
might be the one here like sitting and
talking but those guys in chat those are
the ones that help me make it happen you
know my my clan mates they when i'm like
hey man this
you know so and so needs help and they
just show up you know they're amazing so
definitely want to thank my clan for
for making it happen
thanks guys
salute she's got the love for the
v4 vengeance what's the clan name from
or who made it what's the word
it's kind of old it's kind of like an
old story but
um
it was
it was uh
it's just kind of like a long story so
um
somebody we were that was like our tag
from a d1 clan and he
just kind of defected and kind of went
out and so i i salvaged it and kind of
changed the name to view for vengeance
instead of what it was and so we just
kind of
came back with a vengeance right and
doing our thing
no messy breakup story but we're going
to let that go
i'm just joking i'm just joking
i'm gonna beat this thing faster than
you did
love it love the petty let's go yes very
nice very nice cog what's your
how much destiny is in your future
before which queen
very little but now i gotta go log in
for um mod components
and do homework for that oh my god
yeah i got a ton of those but
you can't do anything with your just
weapon parts is your turn
i meant to say yeah yeah excuse me i'm
sorry but you're correct weapon point
parts um
i got pretty much what i need i know my
clan shout out to dj shout out to you
know forte they are like you've got to
get your 1k i've given up i'm like look
i'm okay
if it's not meant to be it's not meant
to be i'm not going crazy they are like
insisted to continue to try to run riven
for me you know so maybe yeah
while you have dj being talked about can
i call him out on this show yes please
we'll go find him
for his mad disrespect yes yes
this guy
this guy was so offended by my opinions
last week
about about of all things to be offended
about that i say i say a lot of things
that people disagree with and destiny
but of all the things to be offended
about my dislike of ammo synths one of
the worst mechanics ever introduced in
destiny
because of that this guy ships me to
enormous boxes of crayola crayons
and
and tells me to eat them okay
so i
i
first of all it's disturbing that he has
my address but apparently everybody has
my address thank you for that uh
e3 salute
thanks for thanks for making sure
everyone in the world has taken credit
yes good job
um
and two uh
have you ever shipped crayons
i'm sorry with that
i'm sorry what is what did you just say
have you ever shipped crayons
say the last word
crayons there you go all right cool just
checking
oh my god
thesaurus over here
you're fine continue no no
you knew what i was doing thank you
somebody got it yes
if you have ever shipped crayons
then
you know
that they don't show up
intact
it is a mess in there you open the bag
and it is just the tips are broken off
the colors are all mashed together it's
disgusting and so uh he i basically
opened a bag that was uh a a a goopy
mess
so
thanks for that
oh monster he's a beast absolute beast
e
what
oh just in general
for what
no just a general question
necro did have a super chat uh five
dollar super chat necromancer
i can't tell if that's an expiration
xyle
there's probably a story behind that
name what exotic does everyone miss from
destiny one for me it's icebreaker
that's actually a good one because
there's not a lot of that are left from
there i was like there's a lot of them
that are indeed one icebreaker is
probably one of the most unique
um we have
like zlo supercell would be another one
it's kind of risk runner but kind of not
what about you guys any d1 exotics that
we don't have already
vixen
a touch of malice that's twilight
garrison
okay twilight garrison
give titans back that dash
especially if they're going to be adding
rift titans need that mobility to
compete and rift 100
why because they have the least mobility
right now
what did you hear that they might bring
back rift
oh no they've actually mentioned yeah
they mentioned rift
is one of the game modes that's supposed
to come back during which queen plus two
other movies
blackburn's tweet
dissertation about pvp was a thing it's
somewhere in that old tweet from jove
which somebody might have it saved
somewhere but
it is one of those um
yeah they mentioned two modes that
aren't announced because it's all this
reworked for pvp but rift was one that
is theoretically supposed to be this
year
that's so much fun it's the same thing
same time they mentioned like the
cadence of the maps that are coming out
yeah i loved that mode but i feel like
in d2 titans are a huge disadvantage as
the carrier and i was a really really
good carrier in rift as a titan in d1
and so part of the reason i was able to
dash around corners and and beat people
at that game was i just had twilight
garrison unlock he was constantly
absolutely so you remember um sarah
sarah said touch up malice right yeah
she said touch yeah that's a unique one
what are you really gonna do with it i
don't know but i loved that weapon
because just everything about it it was
hard to get
it was cool looking and it just got
cooler as you used it and if you you
know have the right people around you
like your
titan bubble popped you can
step a foot in there and survive
yeah it was definitely unique and i love
the
just the way you like built the weapon
too like the look of like it draped over
kind of the heart it was always it was a
very unique one that was a raid exotic
that was
true to like true to the raid had the
heart of the raid in it kind of had a
feel
unfortunately as you said it doesn't
have much purpose outside of it because
it kills you yeah but in the raid yeah
nice to have necrochasm actually siva
just said it necrochasm
uh if you want to talk about one that
was a pain in the butt to get trying to
get that initial drop from oh that
dropped yeah
oh yeah that was brutal that took me a
long time to get nutcrackasm i do
remember that grind
i do remember i do remember so layla is
another one even though i didn't play
warlock oh i love to layla
because everybody's like oh it sucks to
sit here and wait on your you know to
resurrect again we can't do anything
with it and now you're just like guess
what i have a beast gun if i don't use
my super the entire time like that was a
uni i like that twist some of those
choices they made
as soon as you said it too like i
remembered exactly what it sounded like
you know it was so
distinct
i remember the only one i want but i
don't it doesn't have any function now
it wouldn't have any functionality if it
came back from an um exotic armor
standpoint but i just love the way it
was at helm of in most like what what's
the no no the warlock one that was that
res dude that had the wings
oh man what's that i'm blanking well
they can't bring that one back because
that is gone yeah because it basically
helped fast res people in trials it did
a little extra what is the name of that
it was so cool looking and you had the
little wings wall actually i know what
i'm talking about what was the
phoenix
name
what was it phoenix something light
beyond nemesis
light that sounds about right
something like that i'm trying to look i
just love the way it looked
yeah it's got like the wings down the
sides yeah yeah one of the coolest
warlock exotic helmets i just love the
way it looked that's all but like beyond
nemesis yeah erock said yeah it is like
beyond it yeah it was like something
yeah
red death yeah we got basically crimson
that would be great right that's a pulse
would be nice because yeah i don't
always like crimson crimson's not bad in
pvp
but yeah for pve i would love the range
of a pulse with that healing capability
would be nice
thank you do you guys think um
class exclusive weapons was a good idea
yeah i'd love to see those
something to set them apart
i worry about the i worry about the
already completely imbalanced sandbox
yeah i probably on the other side
yeah probably on the other side of it
just only because they changed the
sandbox so much you know what i mean but
yeah i mean it was cool
what if one of those exotics is really
good you know yeah
yeah it's always cool when it gives a
low usage class a lot of functionality
but then you kind of crutch on that
exotic four said clash you don't wrote i
mean that's what a lot of exotics do in
theory is they make a lot of like hey
this isn't that great let's find a way
to make people use it with i mean if
they push you into something and it gets
better i don't know i would like the
idea of the classes to have more
identity than they do
okay just in general for because right
now it's like everybody gets the same
armor everybody uses the same weapons
there's not a whole lot of exclusivity
besides yes you have abilities and
supers i get that but it's like most of
your gear is not exclusive
like the armors are armor it's all
completely different well it is but it's
like the functionality is the exact same
like the functionality of the armor is
the same but in the weapons i just i
think it would be cool to
yeah we are going to get unique spears
that is true the glaive
i think there's going to be unique
versions of those maybe looks or
something so we'll get our each versions
of those yep
cool
well i don't have a whole lot else it's
always one of these things i'm like hey
is it going to be a spicy one and then
we finally get to the end i'm like it
was kind of spicy not too bad though
but as we do wrap this thing up um
right on about two hours too not too
shabby uh i wanted to ask
uh sarah if you want to let people know
basically where to find you in the world
of sherping the best place to track you
down if they have questions about
raids on twit just anywhere they can
find you anywhere they can look for you
if they're looking for ray to help them
please do you have backpack space where
do i go
let everybody know
yeah twitter you can find me there uh
the sarah janae but i know my middle
name is kind of
kind of hard to spell
so that's okay if you just looked for
the vertigo vixen on there you could
find us or
um
p4v i think you could probably track us
down through that too
or um
ah that's pretty much it xbox
you can message me on xbox or on bungie
on twitter we're out there
salute
let's add you on on xbox right now yeah
yes
i salute to the vixx a tremendous a lot
of fun love hearing those stories love
hearing the sherpa and the raid stuff
and uh we're ready we're getting ready
for uh witch queen and
it's that time we're getting into that
time now where we're starting to wind
down and it's always cool it's always
good to have new people in the campfire
so salute to the fixing for coming
through blessing us with her knowledge
and
great gaming experience
yeah thanks for having me it was really
nice
yeah absolutely like i told you yeah no
worries no pressure you have v for v out
there you got your train representing in
chatham kind of loving that they came to
support you on this one which is really
cool but ah they're the best yeah it
seems like you got a really good group
and that you guys are just trying to
make rating more approachable so if you
are looking for a group if you manage to
you know lfg and trip into a v for v run
and you notice that that's their clan
definitely um give them a shout out
because i'm sure it's going to be a
smooth run because they seem like
they're pretty well oiled machine so
absolutely thank you again very much for
coming uh but yeah find her on twitter
look her up just if nothing else follow
her and make her following even bigger
up travis
the vertigo vixen on xbox you just got
like 600 more friend requests by the way
so there you go
let's get it
travis what do you got uh what are you
gonna be doing for the next
five weeks
one game right
oh no
uh yeah so my um i think the embargo for
dying light 2 is february 2nd so i have
until like january 31st to beat the game
and write the first draft of my review
and then uh and then i'll spend two days
editing and working on the video and all
that stuff for it to be live in time for
february 2nd so i've got like
what day is it today the 20th we've got
11 days to beat the entire game and uh
and get through it so it sounds easy
that's a lot
80 hours and that's like 10 hours a day
man
so i'll be doing that uh but yeah you
can um you can follow me on twitter at
tigertravis if you want uh you can read
all my stuff i'm doing for ign on
ign.com um and uh i also do a show on
sunday mornings at 8 a.m pacific
uh with um some industry vets at uh
season the gaming uh this week i'm sure
it will be a spicy episode as we will be
talking about the
activision blizzard acquisition
it will not be as uh
as insane as uh
lord cognito show is sure to be uh but
but i also expect it will be a little
bit more level-headed a little bit less
of a of a
fight a food fight as it might be over
at the iron lords so um you should watch
both of our shows really yes also
you should join me in purchasing an a
cheetah themed shaker yeah i do not
drink i do not drink any liquids that
require a shaker
but i do drink liquids that require that
i represent my boy e
the more aggressive logo by the way was
intentional to reflect the fact that we
got e
real angry and heated on last week's
episode for the first time ever so uh
now he's got an angry cheetah to
represent his new persona online so uh
pretty great
and uh with that mcclunkey lord cognito
what do you got going on
yo again salute to the vixen fun show so
with everybody that pulled up in the
chat it's good to see everybody see the
clan rep and the vengeance clan out here
i like it and uh yeah it's been fine for
me you already know
i know podcasts gonna be a movie let's
just say they put it that way it's gonna
be a lord of the rings extended edition
battle yeah i expect you know a lot of
bloviation and
prophecy talk and
get ready king is going to have a lot to
say but also um tune in because we
should have maybe some special guest
pull up
do you have a guest in line or plan
mystery mystery
okay okay
that'll be sunday 1 p.m eastern
ireland's podcast and uh salute to uh to
finally do my boy mr baddie plays we
will uh check that out if you are on
patreon if not just wait till sunday we
have that discussion as well and uh yeah
everybody good to see everybody like a
lot of people in the chat tonight wow
this was kind of really cool to see
everybody come out and support us and i
want to thank uh trav again for coming
through you know i'm saying i know
wasn't feeling too well and just to see
him and the energy he brings it always
makes the show better but you know
father car gonna be like rest up after
the damn show but anyway
but anyway what you got and salute to
eat man it's proud of you bro um i love
to see your progression i love to see
what's going on with you with the sub
count as well as you know all the
blessings you're getting right now and
it's cool to see my man with the with
the cheetah cup and also yo hit on some
ign articles from my mantra he's working
really hard please support the articles
these guys he out here doing legends
yeah he made it through lessons so he
can do the review for which queen he he
he went through that that's right went
through the trenches that's right
that was actually part of my contract
they were like if you will review all of
the worst games of 2021 we'll let you
review the one game you want to play in
2022.
um yeah also we didn't even get to talk
about my tweet this week oh yeah
right like i thought i've had big tweets
and i saw the numbers i was like holy
[ __ ]
i know dude that tweet is funny part is
i i gained like no new followers it has
like 41 000 likes and i have like no new
followers from it but yeah that was
crazy epic
epic e
uh well for me first shameless last plug
the ubanta shaker you have two more days
yes yeah go pick one of those up if you
guys want to get to improve raid
performance yeah guaranteed yeah keeping
those beverages the temperature you
prefer whether it be hot or cold you
don't have to mix anything the blender
is an optional attachment
so you can just choose to keep your
beverages at the temperature you prefer
for as long as it will usually about 24
hours will keep you cold or warm
uh but outside of that of course thank
you guys for the support on twitter
on youtube of course the subs the count
the views um and just the comments it
seems like a lot of people are getting a
lot of benefits from the guides i'm
doing to help you guys get ready
obviously if i can take that momentum
into which queen that would be wonderful
so thank you guys for all of that and
then just everybody here sarah thank you
for uh coming in i know you probably
were like i don't quite know what i'm
getting into here but i do hope you had
a good journey with us through this
little two-hour chat of hours around the
campfire
absolutely
and of course travis glad you were uh
you may go you may get off this thing
and pass out or you're gonna be like as
a zombie you're gonna be a zombie
yeah you're gonna be a zombie playing
the zombie game so just make sure you
get some sleep in between
your gaming sessions that's all we ask
yeah my goal the next three days is to
lay down and play dying light with one
eye open that's my goal so what you need
to do is like see if you can get a tv
above you in bed so you can lay and play
vertical that way the dream
that is kind of the dream
i think that's where we're headed with
vr headsets
there you go that's it
i don't even need to move leaving the
way for us to be that uh use uh use
hashtag um
use code incognito for your request to
purchases
all meta purchases use code cognito
that's important savages
and i don't envy you man
sunday
night i don't know who your guest is
going to be but sunday you are going to
be herding cats honestly it's going to
be
shout out to our 49ers that live to play
another week
by the way we all are 49er fans and we
didn't know that before any of each as
we've met each other we are all 49er
fans last week was crazy my wife is a
cowboy fan so we were literally house
divided for a little while
um 14 penalties later she didn't have
too much empathy for him anyway but it
was asleep on the couch daddy i've been
sleeping to the other room for a week
and a half because we've been sick so it
just works
no it was all good uh but sarah thank
you travis thank you cog um please go
support all of these awesome people
thank you guys for an amazing show and
to all of chat all the very high record
number of you who showed up live or if
you hear it in audio form leave us a
review drop a like on the video sub to
all these channels hit refresh put a
little bot on the igno articles whatever
you can do
support all these people so for this
episode number 181 thank you sarah thank
you travis thank you cog and myself
ibantis it has been